contient du peuple tout entier je perds
dans la fente
nous sommes en 1940 c'est la débâcle
c'est l'un des tableaux du tout nouveau
son et lumière de cléry saint-andré un
spectacle qui se déroule dans la france
occupée et pour lequel il a fallu chine
est confectionné près de 300 costumes
un travail titanesque supervisé par
maguy sa profession directrice de crèche
mais ici dans l'atelier c'est l experte
en patron la robe et je pense que les
programmes on essaye aussi avec les
moyens du bord en essayant c'est avec le
temps qu'on a d'adapter aussi les
patrons d'aujourd'hui à nos vêtements ça
c'est de la chance de ce spectacle en
fait c'est qu'on a beaucoup de de oued
photo on a des livres qui ont été
réalisés que ce soit d'ailleurs sur les
costumes ou sur les événements lui c'est
baptiste il interprète le rôle de
médecin
ça tombe bien ce le métier qu'ils
exercent et son costume trois pièces et
couturières ont dégoté cette fois sur
internet sur les sites spécialisés qui
recrée un peu d'écouté et puis des
tissus en fait donc là suis là il vient
mais en revanche pour les résistances
qui est important c'est de la vérité en
fait des styles de vie puisqu'on veut
avoir à la fois des gens de la campagne
des gens de la ville
et c'est vrai que dans ces années 30 40
la mode c'est les grandes modiste à la
fois sur les chapeaux et sur les sur les
costumes et les lignes sont vraiment
défini c'est très créatif en sachant
qu'il ya des choses qui sont vraiment
d'époque ample et les canadiennes on
trouve plus et canadiennes qui
caractérise un certain nombre de
deux personnages notamment autour du
maquis bombe à céder quand on trouve où
on est on est content parce qu'on dit ça
on est vraiment dans l'époque pour être
au plus près de la vérité historique
les auteurs du son et lumière de cléry
se sont appuyés sur les conseils avisés
de témoins de l'époque où deux
spécialistes de cette période de
l'occupation en gardant le souci du
détail et des gendarmes qu'on a fait et
on a fait faire les les touts les
écussons les a fait faire avec c'est un
brodeur de maizière on va faire à manger
local assez long car en plus moi comme
je travaille à côté je met pratiquement
un mois le faire confectionner à
l'atelier au réaliser à la maison
les costumes ont demandé des milliers
d'heures de travail à la vingtaine de
couturières bénévoles dans le spectacle
mag y campe le rôle d'une épicière et
son costume de combattante de l'ombre
glané à emmaüs est fin prêt pour la
première
rendez-vous à partir du 20 juillet à
cléry saint-andré pour ce grand
spectacle sur la résistance